[Música]
Esta es la pregunta del millón de
dólares en Europa por qué no hay un
Google europeo Por qué Parece que Europa
es un cementerio de elefantes en lo que
empresas se refiere
para que os hagáis una idea de las cinco
mayores empresas de todo el mundo cuatro
son estadounidenses y además nacieron a
partir de 1975 en Europa sin embargo es
habitual que las mayores empresas
nacieran mucho antes algunas como nes
Leo roche nacieron en el siglo XIX e
incluso las empresas farmacéuticas que
crearon un gigante como novartis
nacieron nada más y nada menos en los
siglos 17 y 18
a ver al César lo que es del César estas
empresas se merecen en un aplauso por
haber conseguido sobrevivir en el
mercado durante tantos siglos pero no
deja de ser significativo que ninguna
empresa joven europea está en este top 5
mientras que en Estados Unidos 3 de las
cinco empresas más grandes son más
jóvenes que muchos de los que estaréis
viendo Este vídeo incluyéndome a mí
mismo Esto indica una cosa Estados
Unidos está muy por delante de Europa en
lo que Innovación respecta ojo esto no
significa que no haya empresas en Europa
que no hayan innovado por ejemplo SAP es
un programa que utilizan las grandes
empresas y los contables o Skype pues en
fin todos lo conocemos estas empresas
nacieron en Alemania y en Estonia
respectivamente Pero son muy pocas
cuando las comparamos con Estados Unidos
hasta ahora Este era un debate más de
los muchos que había en Europa pero
ahora es el debate más importante que
habrá que plantear en los próximos años
y diréis por qué pues por la crisis de
la energía
[Música]
habéis oído bien la crisis que estamos
viviendo ahora mismo afecta por supuesto
a los ciudadanos con facturas
estratosféricas de la luz pero sabéis a
quién más afectan estas subidas de
precio exacto a las empresas empresas
que puede que huyan de una Unión Europea
agonizante que ya no ofrece gas y
energía bajo coste la Unión Europea ya
no es más competitiva que Estados Unidos
ni que china podríamos estar hablando en
unos años de la Unión Europea como una
especie de Detroit a nivel continental
de hecho al igual que ocurrían Detroit
la Industria Del automóvil es
importantísima en toda Europa no solo en
Francia o en Alemania por ejemplo en
España la automoción representaba en
2020 casi el 8% de todo el pib En otras
palabras que la comparación con Detroit
no es ninguna broma Y si eres fiel
seguidor de este canal ya sabrás lo que
significa ser Detroit faro barrios
marginales y delincuencia Cómo se puede
cambiar esta tendencia Cómo puede Europa
acercarse más al modelo de silicon
Valley puede la Guerra de Ucrania hacer
que la Unión Europea reviva hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
tengo que hacer un anuncio por si alguno
todavía no lo conoce todavía no os
habéis suscrito aviso al economic se del
Canal hermano de la familia visualpolity
como su propio nombre indica visual
economic está dedicado a Exacto la
economía es un canal de divulgación de
economía donde os contamos todo lo que
siempre quisisteis a ver de esta ciencia
y nunca os atrevisteis a preguntar cosas
como que es el pib Qué pasaría si
latinoamérica se dolariza o incluso
asuntos más filosóficos como Qué
cantidad de dinero nos hace felices
creedme Si os gusta visualpolitik os
encantará visual económico lo hemos
puesto meses de cariño y de trabajo y de
hecho en menos de un año ya tenemos más
de 200.000 suscriptores Así que si
todavía no lo conocéis echadle un
vistazo porque seguro que os gusta y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
historia de dos lugares
si visual política existiera en los años
50 del siglo XX habría dos lugares de
los que os hablaríamos sin parar silicon
Valley y Detroit en Michigan y os
preguntaréis Pero por qué Detroit Pues
sí en los años 50 Detroit agrupó
principalmente una gran industria de
automóviles con marcas tan conocidas
como Ford o Chevrolet de hecho muchísima
gente empezó a mudarse allí igual que en
silicon Valley llegando a ser casi 2
millones de personas en esta ciudad por
el otro lado la otra hermana exitosa de
Estados Unidos a partir de los años 50
fue y sigue siendo silicon Valley
sabréis decirme dónde se encuentra el
éxito inicial de este Valle pues para
aquellos que no lo sepáis se encuentra
nada más y nada menos que en la guerra
[Música]
sí lo habéis escuchado bien durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial Estados Unidos
estaba concentrado luchar contra Japón
en el Pacífico Así que California empezó
a recibir un montón de inversión y de
empleados para abrir todo tipo de
fábricas y empresas con las que
abastecer el esfuerzo militar Así que
podemos decir que silicon Valley se
encontraba en el lugar y en el momento
adecuados no solo estaba situado en
California sino que además tenía una
importante comunidad Universitaria en
Palo Alto y por tanto profesionales muy
cualificados y como la guerra no solo
demandaba productos básicos sino también
tecnologías muy avanzadas para la época
de repente este lugar comenzó a despegar
por ejemplo muchísimas empresas
empezaron a desarrollar aquí nuevos
semiconductores para las bombas y así lo
que más tarde sería conocido como
silicon Valley se convirtió en una pieza
clave para el esfuerzo de guerra
pero ojo porque esta semilla germinó
porque esta zona era un terreno
especialmente fértil para las empresas y
uno de los responsables de esta
fertilidad empresarial es este señor que
veis en pantalla
hablamos del profesor Frederick terman
el padre de la conexión entre la
universidad y la empresa privada terman
entendía que las universidades producen
conocimiento pero que solo empresarios
quienes convierten esos desarrollos en
Innovación es decir en productos útiles
para la sociedad con esta idea en la
cabeza trabajo destajo para abrir la
universidad a las empresas y estrechar
lazos con ellas Bajo su perspectiva las
empresas financiarían e impulsarían los
proyectos de investigación de la
universidad lo que le daría a estas
muchos más recursos y también una guía
de por donde tirar por otra parte la
colaboración con la universidad
permitiría las empresas crecer más
rápido y por tanto con el tiempo tener
más recursos y vuelta a empezar sin
embargo para que todo este proceso
arranque Todavía nos falta una clave
algo que necesitan desesperadamente los
emprendedores
Y qué necesitan estos empresarios
financiación y ahí es cuando llegó este
otro señor que veis en pantalla aquí
tenéis a lorens rockefeller el creador
del primer fondo de capital riesgo de
silicon Valley Ben Rock asociated el
resto es historia
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que el éxito de
silicon Valley no se debe a que tengan
muchos emprendedores porque seamos
honestos emprendedores los hay en todos
los lugares la diferencia es que en
silicon Valley se han dado las
condiciones para que una empresa pueda
empezar desde cero y terminar cotizando
en Wall Street en solo unos pocos años
Esta es la historia de Google Facebook
Apple o tantas otras empresas que han
cambiado nuestra forma de vida y la
pregunta es que tiene silicon Valley que
no exista en Europa lo primero es la
flexibilidad que quieres trabajar para
dos empresas competidoras a la vez no
hay problema en silicon Valley puedes
hacerlo quieres despedir a alguien que
no esté siendo rentable y contratar a
otro adelante en silicon Valley puedes
hacerlo pero no solo eso hay dos
factores clave en esta zona la
colaboración entre Universidad y empresa
y el capital riesgo y por el otro lado
tenemos a detroits
como ya sabéis Detroit es la capital
estadounidense del automóvil una
industria muy madura donde apenas hay
Innovación disruptiva podemos hacer
coches mejores pero seamos honestos
siguen siendo coches Así que empresas
como Ford Chevrolet General Motors que
nacieron a principios del siglo XX
continuaron haciendo lo que sabían hacer
automóviles y No tardaron mucho en
encontrarse con un feroz competidor que
ofrecía coches igual de buenos pero
mucho más baratos empresas japonesas
empresas como Toyota empezaron a dominar
el mercado de coches en los Estados
Unidos
[Aplausos]
además de Troy se quedó atrás un montón
de problemas sindicales Fiscales y de
regulación de todo tipo junto a una tasa
de criminalidad cada vez más y más altas
y la creciente competencia de las nuevas
marcas asiáticas hicieron que las
empresas norteamericanas comenzaran a
cerrar sus fábricas en la ciudad porque
simple y llanamente ya no eran
competitivas de hecho la debacle fue de
tal intensidad que aquella ciudad que
una vez fue el hogar de casi dos
millones de personas hoy lucha por
mantener unos escasos 670 mil habitantes
como podéis ver tanto silicon Valley
como Detroit empezaron siendo zonas
mucho más exitosas que ningún otro
territorio de los Estados Unidos pero
solo una ha sabido sobrevivir y la clave
es lo que ya hemos dicho la innovación
[Música]
Pues bien en cierta forma podríamos
decir que la Unión Europea y se enfrenta
una amenaza muy similar con los años la
regulaciones y las políticas Fiscales y
laborales han erosionado la
competitividad de las viejas empresas y
ahora la crisis de la energía amenaza
con ser algo así como el remate final y
esto es un problema sobre todo porque en
Europa básicamente y simplificando
podemos decir que casi no se produce
Nada nuevo
[Música]
por lo tanto es justo preguntarse la
Europa por el mismo camino de Detroit
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la vieja Europa
[Música]
prestaste atención a la siguiente
gráfica como podéis ver Europa no solo
gasta mucho menos en defensa que Estados
Unidos sino que además el gasto está muy
fragmentado por países y además casi
todo va parar a salarios Y gasto
corriente es decir que queda poco para
invertir en i+d y en el desarrollo de
nuevos programas militares y es que aquí
Tenemos que tener una cosa presente la
inversión militar te podrá gustar más o
te podrá gustar menos pero a diferencia
de otro tipo de gasto público es
mayormente una inversión en tecnologías
muy aplicadas Y eso se nota
pero no solo eso aunque todos los
ejércitos europeos se pusieran de
acuerdo para desarrollar un arma
conjunta por ejemplo un nuevo sistema de
misiles la mayor parte de las
universidades europeas tienen prohibido
colaborar en proyectos militares tal
cual como lo oís en los reglamentos
internos de muchas universidades está
terminantemente prohibido hacer
investigación para temas militares y
tampoco se puede decir que estén
realmente dispuestos a colaborar con
empresas privadas fácilmente Y esto es
un problema pensad que la mayoría de la
innovación militar termina teniendo u
ahí está el ejemplo del GPS o del
mismísimo internet
Y por supuesto No solo hablamos del
gasto militar a todo este que sumarle el
hecho de que las universidades europeas
están más orientadas a la docencia que a
la investigación hemos hablado de esto
en anteriores vídeos de visualpolitik
las universidades en Estados Unidos son
extremadamente caras ahora bien eso
tiene una ventaja generan resultados Así
que Europa tampoco tiene este otro motor
de la innovación norteamericana para
colmo la Unión Europea es una máquina de
regular prácticamente su mayor trabajo
consiste en regular todo lo regulable lo
que dificulta y mucho la innovación por
ejemplo Ya se está trabajando en regular
la Inteligencia artificial Así que las
empresas que quieran ponerse a
investigar pues tendrán que enfrentarse
un montón de trabas y requisitos de todo
tipo luego los medicamentos son otro
buen ejemplo la regulaciones son tan
intensas que las empresas pueden tardar
décadas en lograr sacar nuevos fármacos
al mercado poca inversión en tecnología
militar universidades poco predispuestas
y mucha regulación digamos que podríamos
resumir el sentir general en esta frase
ya que no podemos ser líderes en
Innovación seamos líderes en regulación
declaraciones de honor diputado anónimo
visualpolitik y como os seleccionar
estas regulaciones de la Unión Europea
pueden llegar a repeler la inversión en
Innovación Por supuesto que siempre hay
excepciones
en Europa han nacido grandes empresas
como SAP el gigante del Software de
gestión empresarial si trabajas en una
gran empresa seguro que habrás utilizado
SAP en algún momento o al menos lo
conocerás pero no deja de ser curioso
que uno de los mayores fondos de capital
riesgo del mundo sequoia capital ni
siquiera tengo oficinas en la Unión
Europea están presentes en Estados
Unidos en Reino Unido en la India en
China pero ni siquiera se han molestado
en abrir oficinas en ninguna capital
comunitaria y esto explica que Europa
apenas cuente con unicornios los
unicornios para que no lo sepa son las
startups que llegan a valer al menos mil
millones de dólares y seguro que
adivináis De dónde viene la mayoría
exacto de los Estados Unidos el país que
más unicornios ha producido una friolera
de 487 hasta le sigue china con 301 y
nos tenemos que ir al quinto puesto de
países con más unicornios para encontrar
a un país de la Unión Europea Alemania
con solo 26 unicornios
y os preguntaréis es que acaso la Unión
Europea no hay prácticamente ningún país
que se parezca silicon Valley pues
quizás el caso más similar sea el de
Estonia aquí en visualpolitik tenemos
varios vídeos donde os explicamos a
fondo el modelo estonio un país que ha
buscado alejarse de casi todas las
políticas que predominan en Europa por
ejemplo ha creado un marco fiscal Muy
atractivo para las empresas ha
desarrollado su infraestructura digital
por encima de cualquier otra y ha
luchado a fondo por limitar las
regulaciones O al menos hacer que el
cumplimiento de esta sea más sencillo
cuál es el problema que es un país
extremadamente pequeño con solamente
algo más de un millón de habitantes Así
que evidentemente su influencia es muy
limitada
[Música]
Entonces qué ocurre que Europa se ha
dormido en Los laureles no le ha
interesado nunca conseguir un silicon
Valley propio Pues mis queridos amigos
de visualpolitik esto no parecía
importarle la Unión Europea hasta hace
no mucho
[Música]
mientras el gas ruso fluyera sin
problemas hasta la Unión Europea y
particularmente hacia Alemania las
empresas seguirían siendo competitivas y
el territorio atractivo para la
inversión precisamente por sus bajos
precios energéticos digamos que la
energía barata compensaba el resto de
factores sin embargo los precios del gas
se han disparado y ahora la mayor parte
del gas es licuado y no proviene de
Rusia lo que supone pagar muchísimo más
por esa fuente de energía y por eso
ahora el riesgo de salida de empresas se
ha multiplicado
y aquí amigos de visualpolitik es cuando
la Unión Europea se está empezando a
buscar la forma de poder ganar
competitividad con Estados Unidos y
China la cuestión es como lo hará
intentará crear su propio silicon Valley
realmente es esta opción posible Pues
atentos porque ahora la Unión Europea
tiene una oportunidad de oro
un nuevo comienzo
sabéis Cuántos unicornios europeos hay
entre los 10 primeros lo habéis
adivinado 0 efectivamente la lista de
los 10 mayores unicornios del mundo está
dominada para sorpresa de nadie por
China y Estados Unidos
[Música]
a pesar de esta ausencia no se puede
decir que la Unión Europea no lo haya
intentado desde el año 2008 se ha
lanzado varios programas para financiar
la i+d e impulsar la innovación y desde
luego muchos de los proyectos Dimas de
pagados con fondos europeos son
interesantes sin embargo habitualmente
la mayoría de ellos se quedan en un
bonito paper académico Nunca llegan a
materializarse en productos que marquen
la diferencia y que se puedan comprar y
vender en el mercado entre otras cosas
porque los programas públicos suelen ser
muy rígidos muy burocráticos y casi
nunca están enfocados al propio mercado
digamos que el hecho de que un
funcionario o un burócrata sea el
responsable de seleccionar los proyectos
a financiar pues no parece la mejor idea
del mundo de hecho uno de los países que
más éxito ha tenido durante las últimas
décadas Israel lo que hizo fue sacar a
estos burócratas por completo de la
Fórmula lo que hicieron fue hacer que la
financiación complementará la privada y
por tanto era Esta última a la que se
encargaba de seleccionar los proyectos
en los que tenía que poner su propio
dinero
sin embargo atentos porque esta
situación podría llegar a cambiar por
una simple razón la Guerra de Ucrania
después de que Putin decidiera invadir
Ucrania los estados de Europa
reaccionaron con un aumento repentino
del gasto militar Así es como
encontramos noticias como esta Alemania
da un giro su política de defensa con un
histórico aumento de la inversión
militar en respuesta a la guerra de
Putin de repente todos los estados
europeos van a duplicar su gasto militar
podríamos decir que este nuevo gasto
militar va a pasar por tres fases en la
Unión Europea una primera de simple y
pura puesta a punto de todos los activos
militares que haya es decir que no se
hagan más entrenamientos con palos de
escoba Alemania no puede explicar el uso
de palos de escoba en lugar de
ametralladoras en un ejercicio de la
otan una segunda fase sería la
renovación de equipos que no estén
actualizados dicho de otra forma comprar
armamento a Estados Unidos especialmente
f-35s como si no hubiera mañana Y por
último una tercera fase de desarrollo de
armamento propio Y esto es muy
importante porque este aspecto es
fundamental para el desarrollo de nuevas
tecnologías y esto puede ser esa semilla
que necesita Europa para que germine un
silicon Valley
[Música]
habéis oído bien ha hecho falta que
Europa entre en crisis y tenga que
enfrentar un enemigo común para que por
fin hagan caso a su alto representante
josep borrell o bien invertimos en
Innovación de defensa o nos
convertiremos en defensivamente
irrelevantes josep borrell alto
representante de la Unión Europea para
la política exterior el problema El
problema sigue siendo que Europa tiene
27 ejércitos distintos y hacen falta
enormes sumas de dinero para crear un
nuevo jet de combate o un tanque que
pueda competir con los de Estados Unidos
Existen varios programas de la Unión
Europea para facilitar la i+d entre
organizaciones de distintos países pero
los resultados han sido bastante
modestos cuál puede ser la solución
proyectos conjuntos entre dos tres o más
países Esta es la fórmula con la que se
crearon ya algunos proyectos
relativamente exitosos como el
eurofighter o el eurodrón incluso
empresas como hervas que tiene una
división militar muy importante
surgieron con la colaboración de varios
estados en este caso podríamos ver en un
futuro a varios estados europeos
juntarse para hacer un concurso público
en el que diseñan pues yo que sé un
nuevo caza de combate o un nuevo sistema
de ciberseguridad al ser varios estados
pueden mucho más dinero
El caso es que esta nueva lluvia de
dinero en investigación militar podría
terminar apoyando tal y como ocurrió en
Santa Clara el surgimiento de nuevos
clusters de alta tecnología en este
sentido la investigación militar tiene
varias ventajas respecto a otros tipos
de partidas de gasto público primero Se
busca el desarrollo de investigaciones
aplicadas es decir se gasta dinero con
la intención Clara de crear nuevos
productos y tecnologías que se utilicen
para productos y servicios concretos
segundo la investigación militar se basa
en las empresas privadas y está muy
ligada a los procesos industriales y
tercero se suele tener muy en cuenta la
capacidad de exportar esa tecnología
Esto es así porque el proceso Industrial
militar es muy intensivo en capital y
para que sea rentable un nuevo
desarrollo por lo general hace falta que
se fabrique en masa Pues bien estas tres
grandes ventajas hacen que el gasto
militar suele ser relativamente
eficiente más al menos que otros tipos
de gasto a la hora de impulsar una
industria tecnológica Claro que por sí
mismo no es suficiente hacen falta más
cosas
ahora bien qué tiene que cambiar en
Europa para que todo este dinero se
traduzca en empresas innovadoras
[Aplausos]
pues principalmente hacen falta dos
elementos lo primero es muy importante
que los estados miembros estén
dispuestos a cooperar en defensa Y esto
no es fácil vamos a poner un ejemplo
imaginad por decir que España Francia
Italia se juntan para desarrollar un
proyecto de Inteligencia artificial
donde se establecería la fábrica qué
universidad tendría que hacer la mayor
parte de la investigación de verdad
Francia estaría dispuesta a pagar o a
financiar un proyecto que de empleos en
otro país este tipo de discusiones
pueden retrasar proyectos durante años y
pueden terminar generando toda clase de
sobrecostes a los que Europa está
demasiado acostumbrada segundo es
fundamental que las universidades puedan
participar en proyectos de defensa y no
solo eso las universidades europeas se
tienen que acostumbrar a trabajar con
empresas privadas
y tercero Europa tiene que flexibilizar
muchas de las regulaciones que un
entorpecen este tipo de actividades una
idea podría ser la de crear zonas
económicas especiales siguiendo el
modelo propuesto por listras en Reino
Unido zonas económicas donde las normas
urbanísticas las normas comerciales o
los impuestos se suavice no se adapte
mejor a la realidad de esta industria
esto podría permitir convertir la
carrera militar en Nuevo silicon Valley
a lo largo y ancho de toda Europa
Así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros veremos un silicon Valley o son
las declaraciones de Europa simples
buenas palabras compensaría esto la
pérdida de competitividad por el
encarecimiento de la energía de verdad
la Unión Europea podrá tener varios
silicon valleys o terminará
convirtiéndose en un gigantesco Detroit
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]